le jeu transforme le hasard en destinée
la probabilité en chance la raison en
passion
[Musique]
une habitude bien française qui rapporte
gros à l'état tu rentres le 4
et un monopole qui est aujourd'hui
attaqué par les géants du jeu en ligne
mais dans cet univers plane aussi
l'ombre des grands bandits
[Musique]
un mythe sulfurux collageux celui d'une
activité liée au crime organisé une sale
réputation que le portée par le cinéma
de genre et la littérature dans ce
cliché les gangsters de haut volent des
maisons où l'on joue au poker où les
femmes fatales sont croupières et où
l'on règle ses dettes à l'arme de guerre
ces ingrédients qui font le sel des
polars on les retrouve dans le roman
noir d'un fait divers bien réel
l'affaire du cercle Concorde
quand vous avez un mafieux qui est à 3h
du matin en train de dormir et qui fait
un rêve sublime il rêve d'avoir un
casino pourquoi parce que le casino a
génère de l'argent et B il le blanchit
en même temps
septembre 2006 un cercle de jeu le
Concorde ouvre ses portes en grande
pompe l'endroit se veut brancher des
people se sont déplacés le champagne
coule à flot sur les gourous de la com
les journalistes les têtes couronnées
tous attirés par le frisson du jeu
rapidement l'établissement s'érige en
temple sacré des flancs parisiens et
raflent du poker
chiffre d'affaires de croisière 3
millions d'euros
c'est un Corse qui dirige cet
établissement à la pointe de la mode son
credo les affaires les mondanités et les
lieux branchés il s'appelle Paul
Lantieri
[Musique]
disons que c'est un nom qui n'est pas
inconnu à la fois
du petit milieu
journalistique du milieu politique et
des milieux judiciaires alors pas loin
de Thierry c'est quelqu'un qui est d'une
grande famille de Bonifacio qui
possédait une notamment une boîte de
nuit qui était très connue encore
jusqu'à ce qu'elle explose qui
s'appelait l'Amnésia c'était la plus
grande boîte de nuit à ciel ouvert de
France et qui a explosé en l'an 2000
sous je crois dans mes souvenirs c'est 8
charges de 500 kg ce que la clientèle
ignore c'est que Paul lantierry traîne
derrière lui un sérieux soucis le patron
est mis en examen pour recel de
malfaiteur dans un triple assassinat
survenu à 700 km de là le 4 avril 2006
cette nuit là Marseille on rejoue la
tragédie criminelle dans un de ces lieux
communs le règlement de compte au
bistrot du coin
dans le quartier de Saint-Just le bar
des Marronniers un commando est aux
aguets
[Musique]
devant la télé un caïd et deux de ses
lieutenants n'ont pas pris toutes les
précautions d'usage il tourne le dos à
l'entrée du troquet
je ne sais pas manger
dans ce restaurant trois hommes sont
abattus parmi eux celui que l'on
présente comme l'un des nouveaux cahiers
de la côte Farid Bera ma
[Musique]
Farid berrama la principale victime est
intrus en confirmé de la pègre
marseillese un caïd de cité en pleine
ascension soupçonné d'être un acteur de
premier plan dans la guerre sanglante
opposant maghrébin et Corse pour le
contrôle des machines à sous clandestine
dans la région
pour la police aucun doute la tuerie du
bar des Marronniers est signée de la
vendetta Corse mais ce n'est pas tout un
ADN est relevé sur les lieux du crime et
ce n'est pas celui des victimes l'un des
meurtriers s'est blessés une balle à
malencontreusement ricoché un témoin
était au première loge
et c'est surtout que c'était une
commande de la police qui revient
donc si l'on peut commander après ça a
assuré c'était des rafales d'un coup
après je peux vous dire combien mais bon
une trentaine c'est la partie
entraîner son moteur voiture sans partir
la nuit du crime un homme est admis aux
urgences de la clinique Clairval à
Marseille sous une fausse identité
il s'agit d'ange tout ça fait des Richie
une pointure du milieu corse
mais pour se faire opérer en toute
discrétion il téléphone à Paul Lantieri
qui dispose de l'entrejean adéquat et au
nom de la solidarité insulaire
l'antirie lui déniche un chirurgien
Xavier Monnier et journaliste
d'investigation à bachichinfo il a mené
une enquête documentée sur l'affaire du
cercle Concorde
lui trouve une clinique en l'occurrence
la clinique Clairval dans le sud de
Marseille pour se faire opérer il se
fait opérer sous un faux nom manque de
bol tout le monde est sur écoute donc
tout le monde se fait coffrer à plus ou
moins terres et tout le monde est
identifié sauf que en tout ça Frédéric
chi termine sa cavale il est coffret et
Paul land Thierry par pas en cavale du
tout mais il a arrêté deux semaines
après il est libéré par le juge des
détentions et libertés
et le cercle Concorde ouvre en grande
pompe avec beaucoup de people Le Figaro
la qualifiera la soirée d'ouverture de
soir et puis poils de l'année
mais le triple meurtre de Marseille
amène la justice à s'intéresser de plus
près au Cercle Concorde et à son
financement la piste de l'argent même
les enquêteurs en Suisse sur les comptes
d'un banquier genevois François rouge
entrepreneur atypique dans le monde de
la finance François rouges et l'associé
de Paul Lantieri
yannamel et journaliste au matin
dimanche un hebdo helvet il connaît bien
François rouge il était riche et puis il
voulait d'autres sensations se dire dis
maman qu'elle tournait toute seule
j'étais à la tête je suis le patron il
gagnait et gagner beaucoup d'argent il a
voulu faire autre chose notamment il
s'est lancé dans l'immobilier il s'est
lancé dans l'immobilier en Suisse en
rachetant des des hôtels de luxe mais
c'est également lancé dans l'immobilier
ce qui est moins connu en France et
notamment en Corse et c'est là qu'il a
connu l'antirie il a sympathique marrant
type de la Jet 7 et puis ils ont
sympathisé il l'invitait en Suisse il
faisait la fête ensemble et puis quand
on lui est on lui a parlé du cercle
Concorde encore il faut voir qu'un
cercle de jeu ça rapporte beaucoup
d'argent je crois estime à 300000 euros
par mois donc voilà je veux dire c'est
la bonne opération
ministère de l'intérieur donne
l'autorisation donc rouge je peux dire
écoutez on m'a donné l'autorisation donc
c'est légal le ministre de l'Intérieur
dit ok pourquoi j'ai douté de quoi que
ce soit je veux dire je suis dans une
opération blanc bleue je mets mon fric
pour gagner plus de fric
[Musique]
c'est un peu l'exemple type quand même
peu fréquent mais qu'on connaît ici en
Corse et dans quelques autres endroits
en France d'une union sacrée si je puis
dire entre le monde du financier
qui peut y impliquer des gens qui ont
tout à fait pignons sur rue et le monde
du banditisme
ce dossier attiroir est piloté depuis
Marseille par une juridiction
spécialisée dans la délinquance
financière et le crimes organisé à ce
jour 18 personnes sont mises en examen
deux sont encore détenus et les chefs de
mise en examen c'est blanchiment bande
organisé
association de malfaiteurs non
justification de ressources des délits
qui à la fois unissent l'aspect
financier blanchiment d'argent
recyclage d'argent noir ou d'argent sale
avec la notion d'association de
malfaiteurs qui démontre que le fond le
contexte général de cette affaire c'est
une entreprise de banditisme en novembre
2016 la police siffle la fin de la
partie de multiples perquisitions sont
menées en France et en Suisse le cercle
est fermé dans la foulée François rouge
appelle alors son associé Paul Lantieri
et le banquier suisse semble
complètement paniqué
c'est la fin du monde là je te le dis
opération simultanée ce matin 6h30 ils
étaient chez moi toute la banque ils ont
tout ils ont tout pris énorme opérations
merde le vrai problème c'est qu'ils ont
tous le lancement du cercle alors
maintenant il faut que je me débarrasse
de quelque chose
primorganiser je et mondanité le
cocktail du cercle Concorde rappelle un
schéma classique de la sociologie
criminelle trouver des outils adaptés
pour pénétrer les plus hautes sphères de
la société
c'est par des structures comme celle là
que le crime organisé peut s'infiltrer
dans la société civile et la corrompre
quand le cercle dont on parle a été
ouvert le soir de l'ouverture officielle
il y a une réception grandiose regardez
qui était présent
ça il en a pas été question dans la
presse people mais regardez qui était
présent
les personnalités de tous ordres des des
stars des sportifs de haut niveau des
personnalités politiques même des gens
des médias et là c'est pas innocent et
donc par l'intermédiaire de lieu comme
ça où les bandits peuvent se mélanger
avec les gens qui sont les stars
d'aujourd'hui people etc on arrive à les
approcher on arrive à les corrompre et à
ce moment-là comme la société au sommet
les gens sont proches les uns des autres
on arrive aux entreprises on arrive à la
place politique et là on peut en arriver
à la vraie corruption
aujourd'hui Paul Lantieri est en cavale
et l'instruction se poursuit
les mafieux et le jeu c'est savoureux
mais presque anecdotique aujourd'hui en
la matière le vrai boss c'est l'état il
a distribué les cartes aux trois seules
opérateurs autorisés à exploiter
l'industrie du hasard les loteries les
paris sportifs et les jeux à gratter
sont le domaine exclusif de la Française
des jeux les courses hippiques sont le
pré carré du PMU le Paris Mutuel Urbain
les machines à sous et les jeux de table
reviennent au casino et cercle de jeu en
théorie ces trois acteurs historiques
n'ont aucun concurrent et redistribue
60% de leur bénéfice au Trésor public
près de 5 milliards d'euros c'est le
pactole du monopole
une industrie sur laquelle les autorités
opèrent un contrôle très serré un
service de la police judiciaire et même
exclusivement dédié à cette activité on
l'appelle les courts et jeux oui c'est
un des premiers inspecteurs des jeux qui
était commissaire spécial du casino donc
un des premiers contrôleurs de la
réglementation des jeux dans les casinos
nous sommes dans une législation
d'exception
l'ensemble de la pratique des jeux de
hasard est interdite sauf ceux qui sont
autorisés c'est-à-dire par les textes la
ligne directrice permanente et le
contrôle la surveillance de la sincérité
de la régularité des jeux dans les
casinos dans les cercles de jeux dans
les hippodromes et en matière de course
hippiques et de paris hippiques et
également en matière de jeu sur Internet
faisant appel aux nouvelles technologies
Deauville dans le Calvados fameuse pour
ses planches et son prestigieux casino
Jean-Marie moduech dispose de son propre
badge et connaît tous les codes d'accès
de la maison il est ici comme chez lui
pourtant ce n'est pas un manager de
l'établissement faux air d'inspecteur
d'Eric mais vrai policier il est le
patron des cours séjour en
Basse-Normandie
[Musique]
dans le casino les rouleaux des machines
à sous tournent déjà depuis 10 heures du
matin et elles occupent l'espace le plus
important de l'établissement quant aux
jeux traditionnels comme la roulette et
les jeux de cartes ils ouvrent dans
l'après-midi
[Applaudissements]
avons l'ouverture des Jeux Jean-Marie
vérifie les encaisses c'est à dire le
montant total en jeton à chacune des
tables et les formalités ne sont pas
terminées après les jetons Jean-Marie
passe au cartes à jouer il faut vérifier
les paquets neufs qui sont mises en
circulation
on a d'abord visé le bon de commande des
cartes
donc les casinos sont tenus de se
fournir
auprès de fournisseurs agréés
et quand dans les cartes reviennent on
les intègre et
celles qui sont usagées on doit donc
procéder à leur description
pour qu'elle puisse plus gros servir et
ne pas se retrouver
dans des mains
qui ne serait pas innocentes
voici l'abattoir pour vieux paquet pas
de pitié pour les cartes usagées
à présent rien ne va plus c'est l'heure
de passer à table
[Musique]
chaque semaine un policier du service
passe au moins une fois dans ce casino
les incidents y sont rarissimes mais en
2006 la direction a soupçonnée un cas de
baronnage c'est-à-dire une entente entre
un croupier et un joueur afin d'arnaquer
le casino sur un seul coup le client
mise 200 euros qui lui en rapport 200000
dans un premier temps
à donner donc les
les jetons et les plaques
du paiement et c'est uniquement au
moment où
le Client a voulu aller en caisse
opérer le change que là il s'est vu
refuser cette cette opération parce
qu'entre temps donc le casino avait
demandé un contrôle vidéo et ils se sont
perçus que il y avait notamment au
moment du mélange
les procédures n'avait pas été
respectées on a donc placé dans la
soirée en garde à vue donc le croupier
et le jour
tricher dans un casino est un jeu
dangereux Stéphane Vanel est un artiste
qui travaille à Las Vegas c'est l'un des
meilleurs manipulateurs de cartes au
monde quand une main se termine toi
généralement ce qui se passe c'est que
les cartes elles sont retournées vers le
haut c'est vrai donc tu vois tu as par
exemple là tu vois rapidement tu peux
voir que les autres ils sont au dessus
c'est énorme pour toi j'imagine pour le
mettre pour rien
que je coupe je fais comme dans les
casinos on coupe on mélange tac ça c'est
ce qui ferait je te le fais en plus
comme si vraiment j'étais en train de
rater j'étais un mec qui mélange pas
bien
tu peux faire ce que tu veux mais tu
vois regarde la bombe tu récupères les
quatre as je te le fais disparaître
un bon tricheur si tu mets à l'intérieur
du paquet à l'AS de carreaux toi il peut
mélanger couper etc tu vois
ça c'est
toi si tu récupères par exemple trois de
carreaux tu fais
tout de suite le montrer cher tu vois il
faut récupérer son as
coup d'œil et dextérité au service d'une
illusion quasi parfaite la finalité pour
le donneur tricheur et de distribuer des
cartes déjà choisies dont il a repéré
les positions dans le paquet
techniquement il faut avant tout savoir
simuler le mélange
quand je mélange
tu vois je pousse les cartes donc tu
vois tu peux voir ça et au dernier
moment quand j'approche tu vois je fais
un petit break ici tu vois ce que c'est
donc tu les fais glisser les yeux dans
les autres quand je reprends le break et
je pousse tu vois quand je reprends
pivoter des cartes et je les ressors et
après je coupe et je fais un faux mais
selon une estimation une trentaine de
manipulateurs dans le monde exercent
leur don à des fins frauduleuses rien
qu'une poignée de tricheurs d'élite
dans l'affaire de baronnage aux
barrières le tribunal a finalement
relaxé le croupier et le joueur
l'ancienne employé est aujourd'hui
joueur professionnel de poker le casino
a été contraint de payer les 200000 € de
gains
[Rires]
[Musique]
à une centaine de kilomètres de
Deauville Luc-sur-Mer une petite station
balnéaire idéalement située les pieds
dans l'eau c'est le casino et s'il se
trouve un casino dans le coin
Jean-Marie n'est jamais bien loin cet
après-midi il doit justement rencontrer
deux apprentis croupiers
tu vas bien
le petit jeune s'endort
mais ici attention pas question de faire
semblant première fois à peu près égale
c'est maintenant l'heure de l'audition
devant Jean-Marie seul la police est
habilité à accréditer les croupiers
c'est un métier sous surveillance
donc je vais vous remettre votre carte
professionnelle et vous avez été remise
donc après une enquête
où on a rien trouvé défavorable sur vous
il est évident que si votre comportement
changé
aussi bien à l'intérieur du casino que
sur de grandes affaires à l'extérieur on
est susceptible de vous l'enlever
précaution qu'on vous demande
c'est d'éviter
d'aller jouer dans les casinos voisins
parce que bon on a eu des soucis dans un
passé récent avec des croupiers il faut
garder une certaine distance avec les
joueurs d'autant que bon c'est le jour
en question lui avait beaucoup de moyens
donc il arrivait donc de côté de
l'argent
aux employés pour jouer donc on arrivait
à certaines dérives
c'est désormais officiel ils sont de la
partie
j'étais tourneur en fait donc bah si
c'est un métier qui m'a jamais plu tant
que ça quoi je me cherche un peu quoi et
puis vient internet j'ai trouvé cette
formation là donc je me suis lancé puis
ça m'a plu donc voilà
exit le bleu de travail Fred s'apprête à
revêtir l'uniforme du jeu d'argent
[Musique]
dans court séjour il y a le mot course
les hippodromes sont donc inclus dans le
terrain d'action des policiers du
Service celui de Deauville prestigieux
est exclusivement dédié au galopeur
mais le cheval est aussi un monde à la
grammaire particulière on y retrouve
Jean-Marie moduel et son adjoint Paul un
expert du hippisme direction la balance
rituel obligatoire le poids de chaque
jockey et minutieusement consigné
[Applaudissements]
qui sont en train de vérifier que les
poids correspondent
à correspondre à au poids déclarer sur
le sur la liste des partants
donc ils le font avant la course et
après pour les pour ceux qui sont dans
les dans l'argent c'est surtout parce
que parce que en fonction de leur valeur
ils sont obligés de porter ce poids
c'est notamment le cas dans les courses
à handicap ou leur handicapeur essaye de
mettre tous les chevaux sur un pied
d'égalité et donc par rapport à ça il
est il fixe le poids des chevaux
récemment affecté dans le service Paul
c'est d'abord fondu dans le décor pour
appréhender ce monde qui est chapeau nos
initier même le directeur de
l'hippodrome amie du temps à s'intégrer
c'est pas issu du milieu
à l'époque c'était pas évident
maintenant peut-être un peu mais c'est
pas simple d'y rentrer quand même les
gens sont très méfiants
difficile pour les policiers de pénétrer
cette société du cheval emprunte de
bourgeoisie provinciale et de tradition
rurales elle fonctionne en vase clos
c'est un microcosme le monde des courses
c'est un microphone moi c'est un monde
c'est un monde bien bien fermé bien à
part ou
les gens les gens s'entendent bien entre
eux on va dire
[Applaudissements]
Grégory Benoît fait partie de la caste
des jockeys un cercle également très
fermé
en France donc c'est pas évident de se
faire une place dans tout ça mais bon
faut être hargneux aujourd'hui tu es pro
ouais je suis professionnel actuellement
on est déjà depuis six ans
je vois ça à droite à gauche je prends
le service à un maximum d'entraîneur
pour pouvoir avoir beaucoup de chevaux à
monter l'après-midi en course
c'est parti pour la kazakh verte est
unique pastel Grégory et son cheval
Palom pure son mal parti dans ce prix du
ruisseau des houilles bloquer la corde
notre favori se tient à l'arrière garde
mais il n'a pas dit son dernier mot dans
la ligne d'arrivée le galoper fait
montre de toute sa classe et se prépare
à enrhumer ses concurrents
travailleurs par Mariner Stallone pour
qui attaque maintenant le côté école
avec Marina devant la télé des balances
la propriétaire de Palampur voit son
poulain pleinement assumer ses
responsabilités et franchir premier la
ligne d'arrivée
pour la deuxième place du bord
mais posséder un cheval n'est pas
réservé aux véritables professionnels du
métier cela peut aussi devenir un pari
pour le simple turfiste
premier choix il a pris à l'époque c'est
pareil en France il a pris 42 millions
après on a cru qu'on a investi on a
réussi mais l'investissement a été très
bon parce que des fois le conseiller
puis ça se passe pas toujours bien
un petit peu perdu oui c'est exactement
ça j'en suis à mon huitième trotteur
j'ai 58 ans voilà
il y a un gros facteur chance c'est
comme le gars qui autour d'une table de
poker qui paraît qu'un deux et trois et
puis qu'à 4 5 6 au flop et voilà c'est
tout mais c'est pareil c'est un petit
peu la même chose ça joue à rien des
fois on va dans l'après on voit trois
choses qui vous plaisent on a jet 2 et
3e c'est celui-là qui a du potentiel et
qui gagne de l'argent quoi voilà
immédiatement après une épreuve les
chevaux se rendent dans le rond pour
s'acquitter d'une autre procédure
inscrite au Code des Courses
l'identification chaque animal dispose
d'une puce implantée généralement dans
l'encolure
tous les chevaux sont vérifiés avant la
course avec le livret d'accompagnement
et après ainsi que la puce et on les
revérifie après la course le bon cheval
voilà
après l'identification les chevaux
arrivaient dans les premières places
doivent se rendre chez le vétérinaire
pour le contrôle antidopage
mais 20 minutes après la vérification
électronique de sa puce le gagnant palam
pure reste introuvable
au prélèvement il il est suivi pendant
que le cheval s'est recouvert de la
course et ensuite et il va venir au box
de prélèvement
dans ces moments il tourne alors il
tourne ça veut dire bon ici
pour détourner notre attention il nous
montre alors un cheval blessé et
d'exciter mon hémorragie
qui révélé
e
30 minutes ce délai intrigue les
policiers
au box vétérinaire si on lui est une
demi-heure c'est petit
[Applaudissements]
directement du rond du rond à la au box
réservé aux vétérinaire
je comprends pas pourquoi une demi-heure
il arrive il arrive enfin palan pure
apparaît dans l'aile des services
vétérinaires
deux prélèvements seront effectués sur
le galopeur
dans le box on commence d'abord par
siffler cela un site paraît-il le cheval
à uriner plus rapidement
[Musique]
l'échantillon sera envoyé pour analyse
dans un laboratoire spécialisé
une prise de sang est parfois effectuée
mais elle n'est pas systématique
dans le milieu les cas avérés de dopage
volontaires sont statistiquement très
rares mais en matière de substance
illicite les policiers se sentent
parfois confrontés à une ambiance de loi
du silence
vous en avez c'est toujours les mêmes
qui sont ciblés par contre vous en avez
pas un pas un qui vous parlera on vous
le dit comme ça quand même et il y a
personne qui vous parlera
il se plaignent il se plaignent mais
beaucoup vous disent si on parle
derrière c'est nous qui allons nous
faire injecter parce que c'est souvent
c'est les gros en plus c'est les grosses
familles ou les gros à travers bien et
puis ben au niveau des incendies
la Basse-Normandie compte 31 hippodrome
et 16 casino pour seulement trois
policiers courts et jeux pas facile de
mener à bien les enquêtes judiciaires
pour pas lampe pure le contrôle
antidopage s'est révélé négatif
mais quand on s'attaque au monopole de
l'État les cours ces jeux peuvent mettre
le paquet 5 février 2008 perquisition
d'envergure dans les locaux d'une PME
soupçonnée de placer des machines à sous
dans les cafés c'est l'affaire
visionnelle
visionnex c'est peut-être une
microfaille dans le monopole une bonne
idée sur les bornes pour deux euros les
10 minutes on a accès Internet à chaque
fois que l'on met deux euros petit
cadeau une loterie électronique on peut
y gagner jusqu'à 100 euros
le principe a déjà séduit près de 500
établissements comme ce café situé en
périphérie de Lille un troquet populaire
tout y est vert c'est la couleur du PMU
tu rentres le 4 tu
mais depuis peu l'orange de visionnex a
fait son apparition le patron est ravi
de sa nouvelle borne
il faut dire que c'est une salle de jeux
entre entre le PMU les Français des jeux
et qui sort maintenant donc c'est que du
c'est que du plaisir pour mes joueurs
sont
ils s'éclatent et cette clientèle de
joueurs semble davantage s'éclater avec
le billard électronique gratuit quand
surfant sur la toile
[Musique]
c'est exactement le même profil que le
bon dimanche au fait parce que les mecs
mettent de l'argent de l'argent une rien
celui qui passe derrière avec une petite
pièce on peut tout ramasser
40 minutes elle m'a donné 30 20 elle est
obligée de donner de l'argent cette
machine à randonnée oui elle a pas le
choix il faut tomber sur ça quoi et avec
laqué Julie Cathy me disent toute
l'après-midi ils ont dépensé des thunes
ils ont rien pris moi je suis arrivé au
soir j'avais perdu 100 €, tu sais
j'arrive
20 € sur 20 euros 20 euros sur 20 euros
20 euros sur 20 euros elle sort avec
rien du tout
au salon des cafetiers Olivier sigouanet
le PDG de visionnex présente ses
machines à toute la profession chez les
produits bistrot on est amateur de
brèves de comptoirs l'entrepreneur ne se
prive pas pour raconter sa mésaventure
judiciaire
56 heures de garde à vue Ferrero comme
Philippines
est une machine à sous ils sont venus me
chercher à l'usine à 10 ans le matin en
Normandie tout le monde en garde à vue
perquisition de l'usine qui était pas
chez moi quand c'est le diable Olivier
sigouanet aujourd'hui repris des
couleurs et semble plus rassuré quant à
la légalité de son activité mais il
était très inquiet quand l'affaire a
éclaté le PDG avait même fini par douter
quand ça t'arrive tout le monde tout le
monde a un doute il y a pas simplement
que le dépositaire qui peut avoir un
jour même mon entourage familial avait
un doute mais est-ce que c'est vrai ça
fait des mois que tu nous dis que tu as
pris toutes les précautions parce qu'il
faut prendre toutes les précautions dans
ce métier mais ce qui t'arrive
aujourd'hui
c'est insensé ça paraissait insensé il y
avait une faille il y avait quelque
chose moi-même je me suis dit mais ils
ont raison au bout de 56 heures quand on
vous a dit monsieur vous êtes un truand
vous cachez votre jeu vous abusez des
gens vous avez abusé de toutes les
personnes que vous avez rencontrées
Olivier sigouanet a-t-il trouvé la
martingale juridique pour contourner le
monopole autre question posée par ce
dossier celle de l'indépendance de la
police quand l'affaire a éclaté les
policiers ont été accusés d'avoir agi en
service commandé pour la Française des
Jeux
il n'y a jamais eu au niveau du service
central des courtiers jeux ou de la
sous-direction des conseils des jeux
sous son appel ancien appellation
quelqu'un fluence extérieure que ce soit
sur la diligence menée en matière de
police judiciaire comment en matière de
police administrative j'insiste
lourdement là dessus
aujourd'hui
visionnex poursuit son activité
aujourd'hui vous savez que c'est la
bataille c'est maintenant
vous avez quoi comme vous êtes dans le
département c'est combien
de microfailles apparaissent dans le
monopole mais internet a déjà ouvert la
grande brèche de multiples sites qui
sont engouffrés pour proposer leur
casino poker et paris en ligne tous
illégaux en France une déferlante de
jeux d'argent au nez à la barbe du fisc
et du monopole des opérateurs
historiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la Française des Jeux a déclaré une
guerre ouverte à cette nouvelle
génération de concurrents qui empiète
sur sa chasse gardée elle adore et déjà
déposer plusieurs plaintes
là aujourd'hui nous on vit une situation
en tant que Française des jeux de
préjudice puisque on peut pas concourir
alors que cette offre illégale à
prospérer c'est vrai que les nouvelles
technologies et Internet ont amené une
concurrence à portée de clics l'ensemble
des opérateurs ou la très grande
majorité des opérateurs donc qui ne sont
pas légaux en France aujourd'hui au pair
à partir de paradis fiscaux c'est
Gibraltar c'est Malte c'est les îles
angles normandes les îles Caïmans si les
principaux opérateurs de jeux en ligne
sont immatriculés dans les confettis de
l'Union comme malt ou Gibraltar ce n'est
pas que pour des raisons fiscales c'est
aussi en vertu du droit européen le
monopole contrevient aux règles de
libre-échange de l'Union c'est la
position de la Commission européenne et
devant les menaces de poursuites la
France a cédé elle doit ouvrir son
marché
le dossier est porté par le ministre de
Budget
Eric verte il doit convaincre de
nombreux députés hostiles à la
déréglementation du marché
nous savons tous que les jeux sont dans
le domaine de prédilection de dérive de
criminalité de blanchiment de dépendance
et d'addiction or dans ces conditions ma
question est simple monsieur de ministre
vous vous êtes prononcé pour une
ouverture maîtrisée
quelles sont les mesures que vous allez
prendre pour éviter la criminalité pour
éviter le blanchiment pour éviter bien
évidemment la dépendance la protection
des mineurs le juste retour d'un
financement pour les justes causes et la
pérennité de la filière hippique quels
sont vos réponses
la parole est à monsieur le ministre du
budget
des comptes publics et de la fonction
publique moi j'ai confiance sur notre
capacité à pouvoir ouvrir ce secteur
nous ne l'ouvrirons que si nous n'avons
évidemment en face que les moyens de le
contrôler la plus mauvaise des
situations et la situation la plus
dangereuse et celle d'aujourd'hui
monsieur le député et nous allons bien
évidemment y mettre fin en toute
responsabilité
la loi devrait être votée d'ici 2010 une
licence permettra à l'opérateur
d'exercer en toute légalité sur le
territoire français avec publicité et
marketing mais il reste encore des
arbitrages délicats notamment la
fiscalité qui sera appliquée les
nouveaux opérateurs pourront organiser
des paris sur les courses hippiques
françaises sans craindre de poursuite le
PMU voit son confortable monopole
disparaître et le monde du cheval pour
l'instant s'y protégé s'inquiète il y a
un risque de concurrence de
délocalisation des jeux si nous ne
faisons rien il est évident que le PMU
va s'assécher et que si les jeux du PMU
ça sèche et bien c'est toute l'activité
économique et remise en cause on a pu
constater que des états dans lesquels
ils n'ont pas à veiller à maintenir la
filière économique vous prenez le cas de
la Belgique vous prenez le cas de
l'Allemagne même de l'Italie aujourd'hui
les courses sont en train de décliner
car il n'y a pas le retour aux
professionnels retour financier et
économique aux professionnels et toute
la filière est remise en cause
je pense que l'ouverture va se faire
quand moi je pense ça va être en fin
d'année
on attend on est en train de s'engueuler
entre nous
un véritable risque et ça verte on est
parfaitement conscient
France Galop l'une des deux sociétés qui
chapotent toute la filière et le PMU a
décidé de préparer la révolution des
champs de course nommé récemment à sa
tête Hubert Monza un proche d'Eric verte
il faut là aussi appelé un chat un chat
quand vous avez un monopole quand vous
avez un prélèvement sur les enjeux qui
est assuré par l'État et reverser la
filiip pourquoi voulez-vous sortir de ce
système vous savez que c'est un système
très protecteur on vient d'années
d'années de croisades contre les sites
illégaux que l'on considérait à juste
titre on regarde notre de notre droit
comme des comme des voleurs comme des
gens qui ne payaient pas la filia
hippique le redeur demain ces gens-là
c'est ce que je m'efforce de faire
accepter dans cette maison nous les
aurons en face de nous autour de la
table comme des partenaires à part
entière au même titre que le PMU puisque
le monopole du PMU n'existera plus si
cette loi est votée l'arrivée
d'opérateurs étrangers semble se
préparer mais à l'abri des regards
Paris le 52 rue du Turbigo l'appartement
numéro 14 renvoie à un locataire au
patronyme plutôt énigmatique de
l'extérieur rien ne laisse présager
qu'il s'agit des locaux français
d'Unibet un géant du paris sportif et du
jeu en ligne après des années
d'opposition frontale avec l'État à
quelques encablures de l'ouverture il
s'agit de faire profil bas
on essaye d'être présent de manière
peut-être pas discrète mais en tout cas
pas de manière ostentatoire dans la
mesure où en ce moment l'état travaille
à cette ouverture de marché donc on
essaye de de composer avec cette
situation
en attendant pour Unibet l'herbe est
plus verte à Wimbledon banlieue de
Londres depuis l'Angleterre l'opérateur
suédois a entrepris son ascension
progressive dans le monde du jeu en
ligne
immatriculer à Malte l'entreprise a
installé ses équipes opérationnelles
dans le pays qui a vu naître le
bookmaking alors que les monopoles
européens sont en train de s'effondrer
c'est un moment clé pour se positionner
sur les marchés un moyen parmi d'autres
le sponsoring sportif Unibet vient de
conclure un accord avec un grand club de
foot espagnol
ce type d'opération de sponsoring est
assez cher
environ 2 millions d'euros
mais si tu opportunité pour prendre part
au négociations en tant que véritable
acteur du jeu en ligne dans l'Union
européenne
de proposer nos produits et faire du
marketing
c'est à la fois une avancée politique et
économique pour nous
afin d'analyser au plus près les
championnats du monde entier
l'entreprise emploi une grande diversité
de nationalité dont un bon nombre de
Français le quotidien d'un bouc
déterminer la juste code
en fonction de l'expérience des infos
qu'on peut avoir au niveau des
plateformes des équipes des blessures
des suspensions
on fait ça aussi en fonction de quelques
statistiques
après il y a ce qui rentre en compte un
peu on va dire un feeling
et puis à l'état du marché ce cas-là
concurrence ensuite il y a toujours des
infos dernière minute qui arrive et qui
fait qui font bouger le marché en fait
et donc c'est pour ça que j'en ai match
les cotes peuvent pas mal bouger en
fonction des infos comme un marché tout
simplement on peut même miser après le
début d'une rencontre le book modifié
alors les cotes en temps réel
je fais du paris en direct sur de
snooker pendant le déroulement du match
je change les cotes en temps réel en
fonction d'évolution du score et du
nombre de manches remportés par chacun
des joueurs
de Paris est quasi illimitée on y
spécule entre autres sur les chances de
Laurence Ferrari de rester au 20 heures
de TF1 ou sur le carnet rose des têtes
couronnées quid des héritiers de la
couronne du Danemark
cavalier la princesse Marie cavalier qui
est française est enceinte c'est le
dernier pari un peu fou qu'on a conçu
est-ce que ça va être un garçon ou une
fille quand est-ce qu'elle va accoucher
est-ce que ce sera une naissance
multiple le nom de l'enfant nous avons
établi une liste de prénoms royaux
traditionnels
récemment Unibet a développé son poker
une offre indispensable pour un site de
jeux en ligne mais les concepteurs sont
vigilants en décembre dernier une énorme
arnaque à 20 millions de dollars a été
révélé sur un site pourtant très
fréquenté
la structure de la compagnie était un
peu curieuse
qui vérifie les comptes
du logiciel n'étaient pas assez encadrés
des codes d'accès qui leur permettaient
de voir les cartes de tous les joueurs
la chose étrange c'est que les tricheurs
ne jouaient même pas intelligemment
d'une entreprise bien organisée
simplement grâce au rapport statistiques
aurait dû déceler l'affrode en moins
d'une semaine
sur ces ordinateurs Unibet control le
montant et le volume des paris engagés
c'est un métier à risque
en 2008 Unibet a enregistré pour environ
675 millions d'euros en Paris en tout
genre
retour dans l'Hexagone le Stade de
France aujourd'hui ce temple du sport
est investi par une catégorie inédite de
compétiteurs les joueurs de poker c'est
la quatrième édition du France Poker
Tour un tournoi amateur dont les escales
se tiennent partout dans l'Hexagone
ce jour là en compte 1500 afficionados
il n'y a aucun endroit au monde
entier
tout semble légal et pourtant la
compétition est sponsorisée par winamax
un site de poker en ligne illégal en
France la publicité n'est également
alors ici on évite de provoquer les
autorités
seul l'équipe de joueurs professionnels
arbore les couleurs de Winamax en mai
dernier à Tours le tournoi a reçu la
visite des policiers des courses et jeux
qui ont saisi les affiches de sponsor
du matériel publicitaire donc contre
toute bien en contre toutes raisons
juridiques puisque le Winamax étant un
opérateur anglais et en application du
traité de Rome c'est winamax à droite
proposer ses services aux joueurs
français donc il est tout à fait
inadmissible aujourd'hui que les
autorités s'en prennent à un opérateur
légalement établi dans un pays de la
communauté et d'ailleurs nous avons
porté plainte contre les courses et jeux
et contre le procureur de Tours qui a
autorisé cette perquisition sur les 1500
joueurs du Stade de France une trentaine
c'est qualifié pour la grande finale qui
s'est tenue un mois plus tard mais lors
de cette ultime étape le France Poker
Tour a émigré en Italie il est interdit
en France d'intéresser la partie avec un
prix en argent d'or de casino
les tournois comme le tournoi qu'on voit
aujourd'hui le France Poker Tour ça va
des tournois sans droit d'entrée je
pense que si je dis pas de bêtises on
peut organiser des tournois gratuits et
on peut remettre des lots mais on peut
pas remettre de prix en argent par
mettre de liquide à la fin du tournant
d'accord
sur son physique la dotation c'est pour
ça que la finale va pas être en France
elle va se faire à San Remo le moment où
on va remettre de l'argent aux joueurs
et ben on pourrait pas on peut pas
organiser ça en France
le rôle des joueurs de l'équipe winamax
animer les tables et faire rêver les
foules Nicolas Levy fait partie de cette
première génération de professionnelle
français le job d'une star du bluff
courir les casinos du monde entier
Varsovie Budapest Amsterdam récemment je
vais à Prague dans 15 jours et après on
va au Bahamas de on en profite comme
c'est l'hiver là on est en décembre on
va aller
non partie de nos dépenses nos freins
nos déplacements je donne la chance en
fait de de il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
variance même si le poker n'est pas un
jeu que de hasard sur un gros tournoi il
y a que 10 % de joueurs payés il y a
quasiment que les trois premiers qui
prennent beaucoup d'argent il y en a
loin de la chance de vraiment s'y mettre
à fond et de s'y mettre sur la durée
c'est à dire que
celui qui a une mauvaise un mauvais 3
mois mauvais six mois peut tout à fait
continuer sans avoir de problème à se
poser et le Paris a bien marché parce
que là ils ont ils ont fait les comptes
aujourd'hui on a gagné plus de 5
millions en un an et quelques fois une
dizaine
afin de mieux populariser le poker rien
de tel que des people qui se fondent au
tableau des quidam comme Pierre Bénichou
ou encore vicash de rasso
Stade de France dans un jeu au poker
c'est une vraie mode c'est un jeu très
simple à jouer assez convivial ou on
peut il y a la trait de la compétition
de l'argent des petits gains
[Musique]
au terme du week-end Pierre Bénichou a
pris la tête du tournoi son avant son
jetons est confortable dans le jargon
des joueurs on dit qu'il est le type
leader un mini événement que la presse
spécialisée s'est empressée de relater
il fait un peu araignée sa loi sur la
table depuis hier il y a apparemment
c'est un joueur de cartes un vété mais
c'est la première fois qu'il discutait
un tournoi de poker en fait il a déjà
beaucoup joué au poker format tournoi
avec des amateurs comme ça c'était la
première fois pour lui et une bonne
chose parce qu'on m'avait dit qu'il
était très mauvais perdant donc tant
qu'il tant qu'il gagne ça va
on le retrouve dans un duel avec Vikash
doraso dont les jetons sont comptés
l'ancien footeux annonce tapis 5000
000 7000
et l'emporte pour cette fois-ci
retour en Basse-Normandie il est 10h le
casino de Trouville vient d'ouvrir ses
portes en ces temps difficiles il faut
taper le client petit dej gratuit pour
tout le monde les casinotis accusent une
baisse de 8% de leur recette on fait
tout pour attirer même le plus petit des
portes monnaie mise minimale 1 centime
d'euro c'est la machine de la crise on a
fait le test sur l'occasion de Trouville
en lançant directement 15 machines à 1
centime il y a un peu plus d'un an
maintenant et là aujourd'hui notre parc
comprend 22 machines à un centime sont
des machines ou le client aujourd'hui
pour des mises très raisonnables passent
du temps et juste en face à Deauville le
soir venu les feux du casino continuent
de briller
je vous laisserai pas quitter la salle
sans voir de jackpot a plus de 500.000
euros
quand même donc sur ces quatre machines
pour pour trois jetons de 1 euro on peut
gagner jusqu'à donc là actuellement
551000 euros
c'est un jackpot qui qui attire
évidemment énormément de monde qui se
joue uniquement avec trois pièces sur
ces quatre machines et un jour ou
l'autre un joueur va repartir avec 550
000 euros du casino et ça ça fait rêver
beaucoup beaucoup de gens je peux vous
dire mais le rêve virent parfois au
cauchemar quand sous les lumières du
casino l'argent brûle un peu trop les
doigts des flambeurs
commissariat de Caen service des courses
et jeux cet homme vient solliciter aux
autorités un interdit de jouer inscrit
dans un fichier national la mesure
assure sa mise au banc de tous les
casinos et cercles français
les bandits du Calvados ont englouti
toutes ces économies
puis après c'est bon on arrive pas à s'y
faire alors on va voir une maison de
crédit on emprunte et on emprunte et on
emprunte donc c'est une situation
infernale peut arriver au casino
après manger disons vers 21h en sortie
en faire la fermeture oui mais ça met
souvent arrivé ouais on croit toujours
qu'on va se refaire mais en fin de
compte
[Applaudissements]
je viens de perdre les 500 euros
dommages demain c'est sûr j'y vais plus
j'y vais plus ah non non demain c'est
fini et puis on est pris au jeu
soit vous ne faites rien et vous
continuez à être exclus soit vous
sollicitez donc la levée de la mesure
qui vous concerne si je mesure on fait
une petite santé bureau retournez mais
bon alors
ce que je dois quand même vous dire
c'est que effectivement
on a des gens qui demandent la levée
directement de la mesure il faut savoir
que le pourcentage de rechute est quand
même très important vous êtes interdit
de casino mais c'est vrai que il n'y a
pas
d'interdiction si vous voulez de
fréquenter
des PMU les
jeux de français des jeux
arrêté parce que ça rapporte rien si ça
rapporte à l'état mais c'est tout alors
ça il entend gabolisme et sans me faire
interdire
un loto mondial est annoncé pour les
prochaines années dans le Nouveau Monde
du Jeu globalisé on n'arrête pas le
progrès
[Musique]